[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir de
recevoir Arnaud Adami un jeune peintre
qui expose actuellement à l'espace
Richaud à Versailles nous allons faire
sa connaissance
Arnaud Adami bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation nous
sommes sur le lieu de votre exposition
donc à l'espace Richaud
vous êtes d'ailleurs entre deux de vos
œuvres de vos peintures et j'aimerais
connaître déjà un petit peu votre
parcours comment vous êtes venu à la
peinture alors j'ai commencé d'abord mon
parcours donc après le bac donc j'ai
fait un baccalauréat technologique rien
à voir avec ce que je fais aujourd'hui
ensuite après ce bac je ne sais pas trop
ce que je voulais faire donc je
travaille pendant un an à codipost donc
dans le tri de colis vous étiez où à
l'époque c'est à côté d'Orléans d'accord
et donc suite à ça je savais pas trop ce
que je voulais faire mais je savais ce
que je voulais pas faire c'est déjà pas
mal
et j'ai commencé à vraiment intéressé à
qu'est-ce que je faisais dans la vie
qu'est-ce que voilà qu'est-ce qui
m'intéressait et c'était le dessin le
dessin j'en faisais pas mal oui c'est ça
déjà dès l'enfance vous aimiez tout
petit sans jamais vous êtes dit un jour
je serai peintre c'est ça voilà
exactement jamais j'aurais pensé faire
mon métier un jour d'accord et donc et
donc un jour un beau jour j'ai tenté des
concours de classe préparatoire aux
écoles d'art d'accord donc j'étais pris
à Châteauroux
donc après ça j'ai été j'ai réussi mon
concours pour rentrer à Bourges donc
après un an que la préparatoire de
Bourges tout à fait
et donc là-bas j'ai suivi le cursus
jusqu'au troisième année et après mon
diplôme de troisième année je suis allé
au Beaux-Arts de Paris je suis rentré en
deuxième année pour me laisser le temps
d'apprivoiser la ville parce que je suis
quelqu'un qui vient de la campagne vous
êtes de l'agneau à la base c'est ça je
suis né à Lyon en
1995 en 1995 pardon je suis un peu plus
jeune un peu plus que ça vous avez 26
ans et alors donc vous arrivez à Paris
là vous êtes encore au Beaux-Arts
d'ailleurs vous êtes en train de
terminer il me reste un an exactement
mais vous êtes déjà dans la vie active
en tant que peintre ça fait combien de
temps que vous êtes professionnel enfin
que vous vendez vos tableaux par exemple
mes toiles se vendent depuis
je dirais depuis un an et demi peut-être
en fait étonnamment depuis le covid
c'est le covid qui a un peu déclenché
tout ça parce que les gens je pense
c'était quoi très chez eux ils ont
regardé ce qui se passait sur les
réseaux et j'étais repéré comme ça sur
Instagram en fait c'est vrai alors et de
là c'est parti et c'est qui vous a
découvert vous avez posté vos toiles sur
Instagram c'est ça alors les premières
peintures en tout cas la première
collectionneuse c'est Marianne de l'eau
qui est la première à avoir acheté des
peintures et après de là si on est suivi
plusieurs personnes qui qui vont repérer
en même temps mais qui qui ont acheté
par la suite et après les galeries et
après le marché de l'art quoi voilà
c'est un
conte de fée
je ne crois pas si jeune mais je suis
très ravie que ça m'arrive
et je profite tous les jours merci
d'ailleurs il faut savoir que sur les 35
tableaux qui sont
exposés ici finalement la plupart sont
des prêts de collectionneurs alors ils
sont tous en collection sauf les deux
derniers qui ont été réalisés récemment
pour l'exposition
donc forcément il m'appartienne pour le
moment mais sinon tous les autres
effectivement sont en collection donc il
y a la collection il y a beaucoup de
collections privées et la collection de
la PHP qui m'a passé une commande de
cette peinture autour du personnel de
l'Hôtel-Dieu de l'hôpital d'hôtel alors
on va y revenir alors justement votre
comment dire vos
œuvres vous travaillez par série et
alors ce qu'on lit dans le communiqué de
presse c'est que vous avez envie de
mettre en lumière les hommes et les
femmes qui travaillent dans des métiers
de l'ombre c'est ça
et cette idée vous est venue comment
alors j'ai commencé cette
cette démarche en fait sous forme
d'exercice quand j'étais je travaillais
à Mondial Relay pour payer mes études
tout simplement comme beaucoup de
personnes et
j'ai je me suis rendu compte que je
passais beaucoup de temps dans cette
usine et en fait je me suis dit il faut
pas que je perde ce temps non plus donc
j'ai commencé à penser à quand j'étais à
l'usine et donc j'ai
prix des photos de mes camarades et je
les ai peints pour travailler le
portrait après chez vous après chez moi
en rentrant le soir
vous imaginiez des tableaux en train de
travailler à l'usine et que vous mettiez
en œuvre c'est juste là d'abord c'est
sous forme d'exercice donc c'est
vraiment je voulais faire des portraits
je prenais photos des des camarades et
puis je les peignais à la maison
d'accord et en fait suite à ça je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un truc
intéressant quelque chose de très
sociologique comme ça un peu aller Augus
Sander ou on tire le portrait de tout le
monde et donc j'ai voulu en faire une
série plus poussée et donc j'ai commencé
à m'intéresser donc à d'autres gens que
moi parce que c'est pas moi qui est
important de l'histoire c'est les gens
que je peins et j'ai donc été dans
d'autres usines pour prendre des photos
et pour faire des peintures des
portraits de ces ouvriers
une fois arrivé à Paris et vous avez été
choqué peut-être par ce monde que vous
ne connaissiez pas en tant que
provincial à savoir
les livreurs alors j'étais marquée en
arrivant à Paris par ses couleurs qui
défilent dans les rues qui sont très
présentes qui sont enfin les Verts les
Bleus enfin voilà les gens exactement
c'était des couleurs très visibles et en
fait que les gens regardent pas
forcément alors moi j'ai évidemment sur
marqué parce que j'ai jamais vu ça avant
enfin j'ai pas eu cette habitude avant
mais du coup ça m'intéressait en fait
c'était des prolétaires contemporains en
fait c'est les livreurs à vélo qui sont
le prolétariat contemporain mais qui
sont étonnamment avec des couleurs très
vives et qu'on ne va mais qui sont
socialement invisibles alors en fait ils
sont pas visibles c'est qu'on veut pas
aller voir c'est qu'on les regarde pas
vraiment comme on les voit on les voit
pour esquiver pour pas la rouler dessus
mais on les regarde pas vraiment quoi
d'accord du coup vous avez plusieurs
séries donc les ouvriers vous avez donc
les livreurs vous avez le personnel
soignant donc là on vous a passé une
commande c'est ce que vous aviez dire
tout à l'heure alors là c'est une
commande de la Fondation AP-HP qui donc
il va absolument de 7 tableaux et donc
c'était une immersion au sein de
l'Hôtel-Dieu donc l'hôpital historique
de Paris
et dedans donc j'ai passé quelques mois
j'ai fait beaucoup de photos et après de
ces photos montages j'ai fait des une
série autour du geste du soin d'accord
qui est le soin au sens large parce que
ça va de du serrurier jusqu'au médecin
urgentiste donc il y a vraiment tous les
tous l'hôpital tous les travailleurs à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital c'est ça voilà
c'est ça pas uniquement les soignants et
après on a les bouché peut-être et après
il y a la série des bouchers donc qui
est dans l'espace mise en corrélation
avec les hôpitaux qui est dans le même
espace central au rez-de-chaussée
d'accord et en fait les bouchers c'est
aussi histoire de me réapproprier la
peinture enfin l'histoire de la peinture
parce que tous les peintres se sont
passés un buff comme ça de Rembrandt à
flip Codi en passant par Soutine ou
bacon et moi j'ai repris ce bœuf en y
mettant un ouvrier en plus comment vous
la qualifiez votre peinture
je la qualifie de figurative aussi
simplement souvent on me dit c'est hyper
réaliste ta peinture l'hyperlisme est un
mouvement auquel je me dans lequel je me
reconnais pas forcément mais en tout cas
je me qualifie de figuratif
effectivement alors comment vous faites
pour travailler on a comprendre que vous
preniez finalement vous prenez des
photos parce que en fait vous travaillez
à l'huile qui est un matériau qui
commence qui demande du temps l'huile on
peut on peut remettre des couches et des
couches enfin ça peut être jamais
terminé un tableau à l'huile et et en
même temps vous avez des sujets qui sont
hyper rapide un livreur il va vite il y
a pas que ça à faire comment vous faites
alors
est-ce que je veux dire tout à fait
alors en fait ça dépend des séries parce
qu'il y a des séries pour les hôpitaux
ça c'est de l'immersion donc il y a un
côté un peu journalistique où je plonge
dedans je fais mon reportage et après de
cette banque d'image je crée
pour ce qui est des livreurs à vélo donc
il y a différentes sortes de conception
il y a des mises en scène donc parce que
les livreurs quand j'ai commencé je
commandais sur l'application je leur
demandais de venir et en fait quand je
leur enfin devenir je commande un repas
il venait et en fait je leur demandais
de poser pour moi ce que je faisais ils
étaient jamais d'accord c'est vrai ils
ont jamais accepté et en fait donc j'ai
jamais su trop pourquoi voilà c'est je
pense c'est parce que c'est un statut un
peu précaire aussi donc il est pas
prendre le risque et il y a aussi ça
voilà il y a aussi beaucoup de
sans-papiers donc voilà j'insiste pas
et du coup la solution qui s'est posée à
moi c'était de prendre des modèles les
gens qui n'étaient pas livreurs donc
j'ai commencé tes mises en scène donc
avec des camarades à moi qui étaient pas
livreurs et ensuite de fil en aiguille
j'ai rencontré des livreurs j'ai fait
des portraits de vrais livreurs et voilà
mais il y a un côté très fictif tout ça
c'est il y a beaucoup de mise en scène
qu'on va derrière vous sont de faux
livreurs alors eux ce sont des folie
exactement dans cette série c'est des
fois
et effectivement
il y a pas vraiment de relation entre le
sujet et le peintre non pas forcément
non c'est ça en fait
alors quand j'ai fait ces séries là oui
évidemment ça me manquait enfin voilà il
y a aussi ce truc de c'est un métier que
je me présenter donc j'étais en échange
avec des livreurs sur les réseaux
sociaux mais je les ai pas forcément pas
eux et ensuite j'en ai pas d'autres
essais d'être pris d'être pas c'était
hors travail j'imagine évidemment je
suis venu poser
alors allez boucher je suis allé à
Rungis donc j'ai envoyé des mails
absolument tous les PDG de Rungis et
donc c'est la seule PDG femme qui est
d'ailleurs qui m'a ouvert ses portes et
qui m'a autorisé à déambuler dans ces
dans ces carcasses
exactement exactement
il fait pas très je vous avais réussi à
créer des liens avec ces personnes tout
à fait il y a des modèles qui seront là
au vernissage demain voilà il y a les
liens existent tout à fait OK et ils
sont toujours très ravis enfin il y a ce
truc personne vient vous voir sur votre
lieu de travail pour vous peindre en
fait ça arrive très rarement donc en
fait ils sont toujours très honorés et
quand ils viennent toute la famille bien
sûr surtout ce genre de métier
exactement et alors après vous avez
d'autres projets de continuer la série
ou qu'elle est l'avenir alors il y a des
séries qui vont continuer donc notamment
la série des éboueurs donc qui démarre
juste je crois qui démarre juste donc
j'ai commencé il y a de ça quelques mois
mais qui parce que j'ai eu d'autres de
deadline avant qui ont fait que cette
peinture est un peu instantbike donc là
il y en a deux je crois il y en a une
seule une seule mais c'est une série qui
va continuer vous allez donc pareil vous
immerger
alors j'ai encore beaucoup parce que
j'ai passé du temps en immersion avec
avec notamment un éboueur mais j'ai une
banque d'image qui existe donc en fait à
partir de là faut juste que je fasse des
photomontages Photoshop qui est mon
carnet de croquis voilà je compose
dessus et après ça passe en peinture
d'accord et après vous savez ce que vous
allez faire et ben après il y aura
d'autres séries certainement sur les
livreurs parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
nouvelles marques de livraison qui
viennent apparaître voilà donc c'est
jamais fini et puis il y a aussi
d'autres scores de métier enfin les
métiers des Invisibles il y a toujours
ce rapport avec la peinture enfin avec
ses couleurs fluo en fait il y a
toujours le jaune le voilà c'est
toujours des métiers avec des couleurs
flash et dans ce cas là il y a beaucoup
de métiers en fait les gens du bâtiment
et donc je pense qu'il y a d'autres
séries qui vont arriver comme ça qui
sont pas définis mais qui les égoutiers
tout à fait exactement
je crois oui qu'ils ont
effacé
et vos projets de d'exposition parce que
vous êtes
très bankable comme on dit tous vos
tableaux partent à une vitesse
maintenant incroyable si je suis
banquable ça dure parfois un temps
parfois ça s'arrête d'un coup on sait
pas exactement et profitons
et oui donc il y a d'autres projets
d'exposition il y en a un notamment à
Londres l'année prochaine en galerie
pour la première fois non enfin à
Londres
tout à fait et donc voilà c'est aussi ça
la prochaine aventure entre temps il y a
certainement d'autres choses qui vont se
greffer qui sont pas définis encore mais
des expositions en galerie ouais est-ce
que vous avez des collègues de votre âge
qui ont un peu la même histoire ou tout
à fait ouais il y en a on est enfin
l'histoire en tout cas pas sur le sujet
mais aussi successful quoi qui marche
aussi bien
vous avez pas galéré en tant que peintre
vous avez rencontré le succès assez vite
c'est vrai qu'il y a cette chance de je
sais pas si c'est le succès ça mais en
tout cas c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
regard qui était porté sur mes peintures
très rapidement c'est vrai que ça c'est
un vrai bonheur merci à ceux qui
regardent mes peintures mais on est
quelques-uns dans ce cas là mais on
n'est pas très nombreux c'est vrai en
tout cas en tant qu'étudiant on n'est
pas très nombreux après c'est aussi
propre à Paris parce que les Beaux-Arts
de Paris il y a aussi ce truc où c'est
centré il y a absolument tout qui se
passe toutes les galeries regardent les
beaux-arts de Paris alors qu'il y a des
écoles très bien en dehors mise en avant
vous croyez oui
les sujets étaient plus ou moins les
mêmes c'était pas les livreurs mais
c'était quand même des sujets très
contemporains
il y avait personne qui regardaient
vraiment à part ce de l'école donc il y
a quand même ce truc de
beaux-arts alors c'est une vieille
rumeur ça alors dans les autres écoles
pas trop ça dépend il y a des il y a des
écoles en tout cas en dehors de Paris
qui sont très beaucoup plus conceptuel
je dirais c'est ça
la particularité d'être justement
d'avoir des des en tant que chef
d'atelier des vrais peintres encore de
l'actualité et très technique et
d'accord qui nous apporte beaucoup
évidemment
et qui permettent de révéler un talent
fou bravo c'est juste magnifique ce que
vous faites le tableau sont vraiment
saisissants et j'encourage tout le monde
à venir les voir jusqu'au 20 novembre
après vous travaillez avec des galeries
je travaille avec plusieurs galeries
ouais tout à fait
alors il y a notamment galeries qui est
basé à Bruxelles et Paris génial bon bah
écoutez bravo à bel avenir s'ouvre à
vous ça fait plaisir merci Arnaud merci
à vous à bientôt j'espère à très vite
[Musique]